welcome back to CBS mornings three weeks
ago President Vladimir Putin ordered the
mobilization of hundreds of thousands of
military reservists to help fight the
war in Ukraine Putin's directive led to
an exodus of huge numbers of Russian men
causing very long lines at the country's
borders anyone who avoids a draft there
can face as much as 10 years in prison
Chris livesay traveled to the
neighboring country of Georgia where
tensions are high as Russians arrive now
we need to give you a heads up here that
some of the images in his report are
difficult to watch
hundreds of thousands escaping the
fighting in Ukraine but they're not
ukrainians instead Russians fleeing the
draft at home by flooding the border
into Georgia
relieved to avoid the bloodbath of their
own countries making new arrivals crowd
into a support group where they learn
how to get a bank account get a cell
phone and simply get by in Georgia's
capital to Belize one of them Alexei
takes us to the shelter he now calls
home after driving seven days from
Moscow best song with little more than
his guitar
[Music]
than a rifle he says who are you gonna
call
[Music]
his roommate sco bar flew then pedaled
his way by bike after the government
told him to report for military training
same student because I'm uh like only 21
years old and I got nothing to do with
the any like army stuff
um because I don't want to go to the
Army and go to the war and die and kill
people I guess
but at an anti-putin rally in the
capital Georgians fear the Russian draft
Dodgers are a trojan horse all of the
these Russians hundreds of thousands of
them virtually overnight clearly isn't
sitting well with everyone in Georgia
those here see it as yet another form of
Russian invasion and they're calling for
the border with Russia to be closed and
James knows that they are not welcome
here Georgia is no stranger to Russian
invasion
in 2008 Putin attacked by land air and
sea allegedly to protect Russians living
here to this day 20 percent of the
country remains occupied we know how put
this house was so you're afraid that
Georgia could be next
we need to Senate our soldiers to save
the lives of our citizens in Georgia but
in Putin's Army morale has never been
lower following staggering defeats in
Ukraine troops are retreating and
surrendering
and to dodge the draft conscripts are so
desperate they're even breaking their
own arms and legs as this video is said
to show
the fear
it's like not something rational not
something logic you just
someday wake up and start to feel it
scobar knows how lucky he is to be in
Georgia
time in safety
that Putin can't kill me or go uh or I
am not in jail I'm not arrested how long
do you think you're gonna be here
foreign
I don't know I want to work on my old
job I want to live with my family and my
girlfriend
[Music]
so
I guess I'll be
turned back when the Vladimir Putin will
be dead I guess
and I will be just fine with this
for CBS mornings Chris lives say to
Blissey Georgia
a whole nother perspective you know the
guy with the guitar singing Ghostbusters
is not a trojan horse number one and I
thought the last man we said he said I
don't want to die and I don't want to
kill people no the fact that they're
running away from this says a lot when
people go to war they go to war for
ideas and ideals that they believe in
yeah you can tell that hundreds of
thousands of Russians that do not
believe in Putin's ideals now when
you're breaking your own leg Tony gosh
to break your own leg just so you can
dodge going to my frequency says a lot